hey guys welcome back to another session
by simply learn
today's topic of discussion is java
versus python
so in this session we're going to
compare the two most prominently used
languages that is java and python we're
also going to help you choose the
appropriate programming language
depending on your requirements if you
haven't subscribed to our channel
already i'd really suggest you hit the
subscribe button and the bell icon to
never miss an update
all right i'm sure we've all been in
this position where we've had to choose
between java and python
and it was so confusing
so today let me help you choose between
the two languages and look at what's in
store for us
first we have an introduction to both
java and python
then we will compare the fundamental
concepts of both these languages
after that we will get to know the
various fields in which these languages
are being used extensively
then we will go to the current industry
trends and the salaries offered to these
developers
and finally we will reach to a
conclusion and decide for ourselves
which language is good for us according
to our
requirements so let's start the session
by first getting to know both java and
python
java was developed by sun microsystems
it is a fairly robust and high level
language
it has an object language and so adheres
to all the oops concepts like
abstraction and encapsulation
it was originally designed for use in
small hardware like set-up boxes and
handheld devices but due to the
increasing popularity of internet in
those times it was very quickly modified
to be used in the world wide web
moving on what exactly is python
now you won't believe this but python
was created in the year 1989 like java
it is also object oriented and is a high
level language
it incorporates many english words in
its syntax as it was designed to be
significantly more readable than other
programming languages
it is mainly used for artificial
intelligence machine learning and web
development
so now that you've been introduced to
both java and python let's go ahead and
compare the fundamental concepts of both
these languages
first up is speed
java is a statically typed language
which means the syntax is checked at
compile time and so the execution speed
is faster
opposingly python is a dynamically typed
language so the syntax is checked at the
time of execution
this makes the execution speed slower
when compared to java
next up is syntax
python has a clear advantage when it
comes to the amount of code we have to
write for performing the same task
you can point out how simple it is to
print a hello world in python when
compared to java
python automatically sets the type of
variable according to its value java on
the other hand needs the type of
variable to be defined before the
compilation of the code
java is more commonly used for web and
mobile applications while python is
mainly used for data science machine
learning and internet of things
i'm sure by now you have a good
understanding of these languages so
let's go ahead and see where they're
used more commonly
first up let's see the use cases of java
it is commonly used for developing web
and mobile applications
java is extensively used in enterprise
applications because of its stability
and also because of the large number of
features that it provides for business
applications
android applications are mainly
developed using java
now let's see the use cases of python
python is very popular for the use in
the field of artificial intelligence
it is also used for web development
mostly for the back end part of an
application
youtube is mostly written in python
moving on let's go through the industry
trends and salaries for both python and
java developers
the graph represents the growth of both
the languages over the last five years
we can make out that python has picked
up over time and has become more popular
than java in recent times
this is mainly due to the increasing
popularity of data science fields
moving on to the salaries the average
salary of a java developer in india is
around 4.5 lakhs per annum
the average salary of a java developer
in the u.s is around 80 000 us dollars
moving on to python the average salary
of a python developer in india is around
4 lakhs per annum
since people pursue python mostly
because they are interested in the field
of data science the salary dramatically
increases when they get a suitable role
say data scientist
data scientists get paid on an average
of 10 lakhs per annum
the average salary of a python developer
in the united states is around 76 000 us
dollars
if they get into data science roles
their average salary spikes up to around
110 000 us dollars
moving on to the last topic on our
agenda here we conclude as to which
programming language is suitable for you
depending on your requirements
let's now think about why we'd want to
go with one of these languages here are
some points to keep in mind
choose java if you are more into
software engineer roles and want to
handle systems for large corporations
java is extensively used for developing
android applications so if you want to
build an application for android os java
should be your clear choice
java is also suitable for building
various standalone end-to-end softwares
that run on the pcs if you are into this
sort of thing then java is the language
for you
on the other hand if you're interested
in the fields of artificial intelligence
data science or the internet of things
python is the go to language for those
sorts of technologies
python is very simple to understand so
if you're learning to code for the very
first time i'd suggest you go with
python
if you're interested in web development
python can be a good choice as it
provides excellent frameworks like
django and flask to facilitate web
development
in today's era the internet and
smartphones have become an integral part
of our lives we use our phones for
almost all of our day-to-day tasks
earlier we used to shop at malls queue
up in front of banks and make our travel
bookings at travel agencies but now we
can do all this in the comfort of our
homes using smartphones all of this is
possible because of a high level
programming language called java
hi guys welcome to this video that will
tell you everything you need to know
about the class-based object-oriented
programming language java
java is an object oriented programming
language that is used in a distributed
environment on the internet it is a high
level language that is easy to read and
understand
java is popularly used in console
graphical user interface web and mobile
applications game development and also
to make embedded systems
apart from these java is also used to
develop software for devices it is used
not only in computers and mobiles but
even in electronic devices like
televisions washing machines air
conditioners and so on online forms
banking and shopping are possible
because of java
java is a computer-based programming
language invented by james gosling and
sun microsystems in 1991.
he had a single moto while creating the
language it was right once run anywhere
this meant that the code would have to
be written only once but it could be
used anywhere they named this language
oak because of the oak tree outside
gosling's office later it was named
green then to java coffee which was
named after the coffee from indonesia
and finally to java in 1995.
there are three editions of java each
programmer can learn any of these
editions based on the application they
want to make firstly we have java
standard edition this edition contains
code libraries like java.lang java.util
etc secondly we have java enterprise
edition this edition has apis like jms
ejb jsp servlets etc and lastly we have
java micro edition which is used to
program java in cell phones setup boxes
handhelds and so on
java is an object oriented programming
language based on c and c-plus plus
however it is improved and simplified to
solve the errors in programming java
files are converted to bit code format
using a compiler and then executed by
the java interpreter the whole java code
is run on the java virtual machine which
provides a runtime environment now the
main concepts in java are its methods
and classes a method is a block of code
that performs a task only when it is
called consider this example while
watching tv you use the tv remote to
change channels each button on the
remote performs a different task methods
in java are the same we can have methods
to add two numbers or email a person or
to convert kilometers to meters a group
of methods make a class
classes are used to organize code just
like how fruits vegetables and clinical
products are divided into different
sections in a supermarket
there are a lot of features in java
let's start by looking at them one by
one it has a simple syntax and is very
easy to understand and learn java
language is robust it eliminates errors
that occur in the c and c plus languages
java also has features like garbage
collectors and exception handling this
makes java very unique the most popular
feature of java is that it is platform
independent here compilation happens in
byte code and because of this java can
run on any machine
it is a very secure language as it
contains no virus
java has a feature of multi-threading
the feature of multi-threading helps
java do multitasking java is a portable
language as it can run on any platform
and data type sizes are set permanently
so java program has a fixed size of the
code the last of all java is not as fast
as c and c plus plus but provides higher
performance than any other language now
let's see oops concepts in java java has
four concepts abstraction encapsulation
inheritance and polymorphism in java we
use objects and classes related to the
real world that makes the code easier to
make and understand abstraction means
showing the relevant information that is
needed for a task encapsulation makes
the java code secure
data is stored within the classes and it
is not easy to access the data the next
feature is inheritance as the name
suggests the attributes and
characteristics of one class can be
inherited by another class because of
this coders take less time to create the
code lastly we have polymorphism which
means using the same method for
different tasks in java we can use the
same object or variable in two different
places where their tasks will differ
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so now let's download java let's go to
google and search for java download
we'll go to the link we see here
oracle.com so now here we have the web
page
here we can see java se13 so this is
version 13 but this isn't the one we are
going to download we're going to
download the eighth version version 8
which is here now we're doing this
because 8 is one of the more commonly
used versions of java
so let's click this
and here we'll go down we need to accept
the license agreement before we can
download it
now we have two versions here x86 and
x64 now you can download it depending on
what version your operating system is
now if you do have a windows 10
operating system it's highly likely you
have a 64-bit version of windows now if
you do have a 32-bit version of windows
you can take the x86 so let's download
this
so we've actually already logged in so
we just need to run the installer file
now let's go to downloads
and run the file
so here we have the installer we go to
the next step
we'll select this to next here we can
see where the file is being installed to
we'll go to next
now if you want to change where you want
to install java we can press the change
option i'm just going to keep it here
we'll press next and let's commence with
installation
and there we go the installation is now
complete so we don't need any tutorials
or api documentation so we'll just
finish off and go to close
now to see if java is installed in your
system we can go to command prompt
and type the term java c
which refers to the java compiler
now as you can see here this shows a
number of different options you can
choose from this also indicates that
java has been successfully installed in
your system now if the installation was
not successful you'll see something like
java c is not recognized as an internal
or external command operable program or
batch file but since we've done it
successfully this is what will be shown
now
and now we're going to set an
environment variable now what exactly is
an environment variable now assume you
have a file which has a dot java
extension this environment variable
tells the computer that the java program
needs to be called to run this
particular file
so to set the environment variable we'll
need to go to control panel
here go into system and security
go to system and select advanced system
settings and then this shows up now
before we go into environment variables
we'll need to go to where the java file
was installed so let's go to this pc
c drive
program files
and here let's go to java
so let's go to jdk which is the java
development kit let's go to bin here
and copy this path
we'll go back to environment variables
select path here
and then press on new
paste this
and okay now we'll go back
and go to jre to the path of gre which
is java runtime environment
we click on this
pin again
and copy this path
select this one
new
and paste that
and there we go the environment
variables are now set
now let's talk about running that simple
program i told you about now this is
possible with the help of an ide an ide
or integrated development environment
will give us a platform to code java we
will be using eclipse and intellij as
they are popular and commonly used that
being said there are several other ides
that are available in the market so now
let's work with eclipse let's go to
google and search for eclipse
we'll go to this link
press download and then this shows up
let's click on download
now we've already downloaded the
software so i'm just going to directly
go into the install phase
downloads and select eclipse with this
you can see that there are multiple
options for you to choose from so we're
going to select eclipse ide for java
developers now you have other options
like for cnc plus plus javascript php
and so on let's go to the first one and
here you have the details you can change
them if you want but i'm just going to
go ahead with installation now
press accept now
here we remember accepted licenses and
press accept
and then here as well we'll remember
accepted certificates select this one
and accept selected
and there you go the installation is now
complete let's click on launch now
so here we are setting up a directory as
a workspace i'm not changing it here so
i'm just going to go with launch
here we have the eclipse workspace now
let's close this first and here we have
the package explorer now in case this
doesn't show up you can go to window
show view
and select on package explorer
so now let's go to file
new and java project we need to set up a
project name i'm going to call it my
project
one
go to next we'll go to source so this is
where the source code for your
program is going to be stored then let's
finish and now we'll click on my project
one
go to source
i click new
and create a class
explain
i'll name the class my class
and create it
and here we have it so now let's write a
simple program to multiply two numbers
so now let's write the main function
open
bracket
now we're going to initialize the first
number
now the second one
and finally the output
and finally the variable that will store
the output
now we'll just give them a simple print
statement
now let's run the code by clicking this
option here
using my cluster java
and there we have it here the product is
shown to be 100 indicating that the
program is running successfully
now we're done with eclipse now let's
move on to the other ide i was talking
about which is intellij so for that
again we'll have to go back to google so
that we can download it
how to install eclipse ide on your
windows 10 operating system now an ide
is an integrated development environment
on this computer programmers can perform
software development now eclipse is one
of several in the market like intellij
bluej doctor java and so on now to
install eclipse first you need to
install java this is because if you try
to run the eclipse installer this shows
up this shows that you do need java
before you can install eclipse on your
operating system so first let's go and
download java now let's search for java
install
and then go to this link now here we
have the latest version which is version
13. we're not going to pick that one up
we're going to go to version 8. now
we're choosing version 8 because this is
one of the most commonly used versions
of java so let's select this so we'll go
down all the way here and here we can
see two options the 64-bit and the
86-bit so this basically represents the
32-bit operating system so if you do
have one you can select this option
since we have a 64-bit operating system
i'm going to select this but before the
installation you need to accept license
agreement and select this now i've
already logged in so i'm just going to
install now select this go downloads
click on this and then this shows up
we'll go to next we'll go to next and
let the install complete
so here we have another pop-up so if you
want to change the destination folder
you can select this option this is fine
with me so i'm going to go with next
that's it we'll let the installation
complete now so there you go the
installation is now complete so if you
want to look at tutorials or
documentation you can go to the next
steps i don't want to so let's close and
go back now just because we've installed
java we can't exactly run it yet for
that we need environment variables now
environment variables help the computer
understand that it needs to run java
when it sees a dot java file for that
let's go to the control panel
let's go to system and then let's go
here
and select advanced system settings and
then this shows up now before we can set
the environment variables we'll need the
path to where java is installed so let's
go to file explorer let's click c drive
let's go to program files so this is
where i install java let's go to java
first let's go to jdk and bin now let's
go back here click on environment
variables select a path here go back
let's copy that
and press on new and paste this now
likewise let's go back go to jre which
is the java runtime environment and jdk
which is the java development kit click
on this go to bin and select this path
go back go to path
select new and paste this as well and
there you go the environment variables
are now set let's click on ok and that's
done now let's install eclipse let's go
back again and search for eclipse
in here select this option click on
download select 64-bit so and this shows
up so i've already downloaded it so we
can directly go there i'm going to click
on this now so now we have the installer
show up so here you can choose from a
number of different options like cc plus
plus php and so on so you want this one
we click on this and here we can just
install we'll accept and there you go
the installation is going on right now
we'll remember accepted licenses except
this you need to accept these
certificates
except selected and there you go we're
complete let's launch
so now we need to set up a directory so
i'm okay with this so let's launch and
there you go here's the workspace so
let's run a very simple program now so
we'll close this and here you have the
package explorer let's open this up so
in case you can't access the package
explorer go to window click on show view
and select package explorer now first to
run a program you need to create a java
project click on this and let's name our
project let's go to next and here you
see src or source now this is where the
source code of your program is now we'll
just finish
and that's that now we go to source
right click new and create class now
let's create a class
class
1 and finish and now we should be able
to run any program we want let's look at
the very simple code of writing hello
world so let's open the main function
there you go let's open a bracket here
let's print
and that's that now let's run the
program by clicking on this icon let's
select the class and there we go we have
an output this means the program is
running successfully
let's begin with the fundamentals so the
first one in the fundamentals is the
data types so every programming language
has a data type so what exactly is a
data type so whatever the input you
provide in your program is a data type
for example if you provide numbers so in
that particular numbers we have a
different variety of numbers if you are
given just 1 2 3
so on without a decimal number then that
particular type of input which is a
number will be considered as integer
type if you provide the same number with
a decimal point then that will be
considered as float and if you have the
range
greater than float it will be considered
as double and so on so this is how we
have multiple data types in every
programming language so the most
frequently used data types in java
programming languages are as follows at
first we have the byte followed by that
we have short and long next float then
double boolean and finally care apart
from this we also have few other data
types but these are the most frequently
used ones for all the basic programmings
so this is made for beginners basically
so you can take a quick screenshot of
this particular slide so that you can
have a quick overview or reference to
all the data types in java programming
language so i hope you have taken a
screenshot of this now let's begin with
the next concept so in the next concept
we have the keywords and variables so
all the programming languages have
variables and keywords so variables are
used to store the values
so for example consider that you wanted
to run some automatic operation on two
different values that is 5 and 10. so in
order to do so you might want to create
a variable which stores them for example
you wanted to store the value of 10 in a
certain variable a and the 5 in a
certain variable b so if you apply the
arithmetic operation that is a is equals
to a plus b
then the value of a which was previously
10 will be updated to 15 so here you can
see the value is varying and also it is
storing the result so this is why the
variables are used in a program in order
to store a value and this particular
term variable is used because the value
can change at any instance of time once
after a certain arithmetic or a logical
operation is performed on that
particular variable
so similarly we have keywords unlike
variables keywords have a special
meaning no matter whatever you try you
cannot change the meaning of that
keyword for example consider main so you
cannot use the term main for normal
things
because the part or the term main is
dedicated for a different purpose so
whenever you try to execute your java
program the control flow will start
executing the program right when it
reads the term main
so it has a special meaning similarly
you have other keywords such as end so
that is dedicated for integer type of
values and float for float type of
values that is the decimal values and
byte for byte care for character type
data string for string so every keyword
or every term with special meaning which
is predefined and cannot be changed is
called as a keyword now let's see the
most frequently used keywords in java
programming language so similar to the
previous one we have a table here so in
this particular table we have the most
frequently used keywords in java so you
can see we have boolean final byte
native and we have void switch so switch
is a conditional statement so we have if
if it is also a conditional statement we
will go through this conditional
statements as we proceed in our tutorial
and you can also see the protected so
this term which is protected public so
this is basically the access modifier
even this particular keyword have
special meaning this public this
protected keywords
provide the information to the compiler
or the interpreter about the
accessibility of that particular data
member or data manipulating method so if
it is protected from your accessibility
or is it available for you it's provided
by these keywords so we will deal with
access modifiers in the upcoming parts
don't worry about that and as you can
see we have implements extends so
extends in this term comes in
inheritance so inheritance is one of the
crucial concepts of object oriented
programming you can also see abstraction
so this we will be dealing in the next
upcoming part where we will understand
the object-oriented programming concepts
next we have interface return and so on
you can also see some keywords like
through so throw will come in exception
handling so we will also learn about
exception handling in the upcoming part
so these are the most frequently used
keywords in java so now we will move
ahead into our next concept so the next
concept is the operators in java so to
understand operators let's go through a
table so on my screen you can see a
table which has some arithmetic
operators which are most commonly used
that is the plus for addition minus the
subtraction similarly we have star
forward slash double plus double minus
so double plus and double minus say they
are increment and decrement operators
respectively as you can see we have a
plus plus here which means the post
increment so the first
value will be read after that the value
will be updated next we have the
pre-increment
the value will be incremented first then
the updated value will be stored so
that's that's how the increment and
decrement operators work so we have the
modulus over here so to understand the
operators that we use in java in a much
better way let's try to execute a sample
program so on my screen you can see a
program which is based on operators so
we are currently on the eclipse ide
don't worry about the ids and java etc
etc so i will drop a link in the
description box below which will explain
you in a very detailed way about how to
install java into your local system and
how to install eclipse ide in your local
system and also how to create your first
project how to create your package how
to create a new class how to write your
program and how to run that how to see
the output and a complete overview of
the eclipse ide how that works so
everything will be linked in the
description box below you don't have to
worry about that so right now to save
time i have created the text document
which has all the programs that we will
be executing today so i will also drop a
link for that particular file so that
you can have complete access to that
file so that you can run the programs in
your personal pcs or laptops and also
understand the programs in a much better
way so now let's begin with the program
so this particular program is basically
designed for automatic operations so you
can see we have the operators that is
the addition subtraction multiplication
division modulus and exit so basically
we will be taking input from mu so the
input will be taken by the user
that is we're using scanner class here
so scanner class takes the input from
user and that particular input will be
compared here so we're using the switch
case here so if you provide the option
as one then edition operation will be
run similarly second for subtraction
third for multiplication fourth for
division fifth for modulus and sixth to
exit so this is how the
loop or the program works for automatic
operations now let's quickly run this
program and see the output so you can
see the program got successfully
executed and we have the console asking
for the first input let's provide some
random number now
let's provide the second number so there
you go we have our options over here now
let's choose uh division operation for
that we need to provide the number four
so there you go we have the result over
here which is four now the loop has
started once again now it's in the
starting stage again it's asking for
numbers now let's provide a 25 and
five
now let's choose some operation that is
edition so for that you need to provide
one so we have the result again that is
30.
now
let's again choose some number 10
5. so basically that's how the program
works so we have the brief idea how the
program is running now so now let's
quickly continue with our next topic now
to terminate this loop you can provide
the option number six so we have
terminated it so i hope you understood
how the program flow is running so if
you did not understand don't worry i
have linked the document in the
description box below you can take the
access of that particular document and
you can check the program and run in
your local system and also you can make
some modifications to it as you can see
we don't have a default case over here
i've just placed the case one two six
and
i'm seeing the default because you can
see that the options are from one to six
what if the user provides the number as
seven right so the program might crash
over here so for that purpose you can
write in another case that would be the
default case so the default case will
check if the number is anything above or
out of the range of one to six then it
should be providing you with an output
saying a wrong input has been given or
check your input or something similar so
that's how you can make some
modifications to it you're free to
modify the code as well don't worry
about that so now let's quickly begin
with our next concept so in the next
concept we have the conditional
statements so what are the conditional
statements or the control statements so
basically these are some
yeah these are conditions so what
happens is just imagine that you wanted
to do something or if you wanted to
drive a vehicle or if you wanted to
drive a bike so the condition you will
apply on your mind is if i know driving
then i will do it if not i'll not do it
so that's what you do right so basically
you apply a condition on your mind and
you do it if it is capable of doing or
if you are capable of doing it so in the
same way the conditional statements play
a major role in computer logic so before
writing a code or before you start your
program you provide the condition
perform this particular operation if the
provided condition is satisfied so
similarly you have
these three conditional statements in
java which are if if else and nested if
so we use these conditional statements
in java to implement our logic so we
will understand the conditional
statements particularly if if else and
necessatif in a much more detailed way
by practically running some programs
based on these three types of
conditional statements so now you can
see that we are back on the eclipse
right now so this particular code
segment is based on the if condition i
hope the program is visible let's try to
increase the font size so i think it's
better now so basically we have an input
so we have the integer type of input
that is num and we have the number as
minus 100 so it is a negative number and
after that we have the if condition so
this is where the conditional statement
is provided so the condition is if the
number is greater than zero if the
provided number is greater than zero
then the control should enter the loop
which is this particular segment and
execute the statements present inside
that particular loop so here we have one
single statement that is a print
statement that says the number is
positive in case the condition fails
imagine that the condition fails then
what happens is that instead of entering
this particular code segment this
particular code segment the control will
skip and execute the next statement that
is another printf statement which we
have over here which says the if
condition is terminated control is
outside the condition block now since we
have provided a negative number the
second option should go ahead now let's
try to run this and see the output so
there you go as expected the program got
executed and we have only one statement
that is if condition is terminated
control is outside the block now let's
write otherwise let's just eliminate the
negative number and now check it again
there you go now you can see the program
got executed and now we have two print
statements you can see that the
condition here was true so the control
entered into the statement or the code
block and this particular statement got
executed successfully once the
statements are executed and there is
nothing else to do then the control will
automatically exit this particular
statement and it will enter into the
next statement which is another printf
statement and we have the same output
over there so this is how the single if
statement works so you can also modify
this with an else so that's the next
program that we are going to see we are
going to execute some similar kind of
example
for our next kind of conditional
statement that is if else so here only
we had one if condition so in case if
this particular condition fails then we
will be having another condition over
here which will be the else block so as
you can see we have another program so
this particular program is based on if
else condition so here you can see that
we have our first if condition which
states number should be greater than or
equals to zero if this particular
condition is true then this statement
should be executed which says the number
is positive else
else if this condition fails then what
you must do the control should avoid
entering this particular segment and it
should directly hit the next segment
where we have the else block which has
another statement which says the number
is negative so this is how the program
works so here we will be doing a little
modification over there instead of
taking an input which is previously
defined as it was in the previous
example where we had given minus 100
previously we are going to do it a
little differently this time we'll be
taking or reading the input directly
from the user so for that we are going
to use this scanner class so this is the
particular library that we will be using
so we have imported java.util.scanner
so this particular code segment will ask
you for the input and you will press
some random number and it will read it
as its input now let's try to quickly
run this program and see the output
there you go the program was
successfully executed and now it is
asking for an input from the user now
let's try to provide a negative number
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and you can see
that since we had given a negative
number the control did not enter this
particular code segment at all it
directly avoided to enter this code
segment and entered into the else block
and executed the statements present in
that particular else block which was a
simple print statement that had the
statement which read as the number is
negative now let's try to execute the
same program again and see what would be
the output so there you go now it's
asking for the input again now this time
let's provide a positive number so there
you go since we provided the number as a
positive number this condition was true
and this particular statement got
executed since one of the statements
executed there was no need for the else
block to be executed again so you can
see this particular code segment runs in
this way so once the condition is
checked so if the condition is true then
the true statement will be executed in
case if the conditions result is false
then the false statements will be
executed so you will be provided with
two options so one option for true
validity and another option for false
validity so this is how the if else
block works i hope you understood this
now with this let's continue with the
next type of conditional statement that
is the elsef ladder so on my screen you
can see there is a change of program we
have stepped into the next type of
conditional statement that is the elsef
ladder so basically everything will be
seen we will be provided with only one
condition so we will be checking the
validity of that particular condition so
if the provided condition is true then
the first one will be executed if it is
not then the second one will be executed
if the condition fails for the first two
the third one will be executed if the
first three failed and the fourth and if
all the four fails then we will have one
last else which will print the last
segment or statement so this is how the
elsif ladder works so basically it's
completely similar to if else but the
only difference is instead of one else
block we have multiple else blocks
that's the only difference now let's
quickly execute this program and say the
output so basically we are going to
take an input from the user so we will
be entering one for noodles two for
milkshake three for fruits four for
coffee so something like that and if we
provide anything else then one two three
four then we will be having an else
statement which says it's an invalid
input so the flow of this particular
elsif statement is similar to the switch
statement having said that we will also
discuss something about switch statement
as well basically we'll try to execute a
program based on a switch statement and
we'll also understand the control flow
of that don't worry about it now let's
quickly execute this particular program
first so there you go the program got
successfully executed now it's asking
for an input uh let's select noodles
that's how it works we have the output
nodals so the choice is equal to is
equals to one so the first one was true
so it executed the first code segment
and everything else got suspended
because this was not necessary to be
executed because the condition was true
over here and according to that only
this particular statement was supposed
to be executed so that's how it works
now let's switch into the next
conditional statement which is the
switch so you can see that we have a
program on my screen which is based on
switch case
so you can see that there is some
similarity between this particular
program and the first program we dealt
with that is based on operators so we
also have the default code segment over
here so this was what i was talking
about you can add a default code segment
in that particular program which is the
operators program and do some
modifications so this is what the
suggestion i gave over there now
basically what happens in this
particular code segment is so we have
monday as the day one of a week tuesday
at the day two of the week and so on so
uh to select one particular day of a
week you need to provide an input so
it's based on one two three four and so
on to seven and if you provide anything
else than one two seven you will be
provided with an message which says
invalid input so now let's try to
run this program and see the output so
there you go the program got
successfully executed now let's select
the weekend day so which would be
something between six and seven so six
is saturday and seven is sunday let's go
with seven so there you go sunday now
let's try to execute this program once
again and give a wrong input and see if
it works or not let's provide 8
there you go the program identified it
as a wrong input so it gave us a message
invalid input so that's the use of
default code segment in switch case so
you can implement this in that operators
program and check out how it works can
be considered as a homework though not a
problem now this is how the switch case
works so with this let's move ahead into
the next concept in our java tutorial
for today so the next segment is about
the loops so what are loops
so conditional statements are
some statements which get executed based
on a condition if the condition is true
if not then that particular condition
will not be executed loops are a little
different from conditional statements
how so basically you will be provided
with one single statement and you wanted
to execute that one single statement for
a particular number of times
so in that condition instead of writing
the same code segment for several number
of times you can just use a loop for
example consider that you wanted to
print numbers from 1 to 10 so the brute
force method or the simple or the first
method that fires to your mind is write
that print statement for 10 times that
is print 1 print 2 print 3 and so on to
print 10 but what if you had to print
hundred numbers
okay doable you can write the same print
statement for 100 times but what if you
had to print thousand numbers
imagine one billion can you do one
billion print statements no right so in
that scenario you can use loops so you
can just write one condition
repeat this particular print statement
for one billion times then the
interpreter or the compiler will take
care of that so that's the reason why we
use loops in java so basically we have
three loops in every programming
language that is the for loop while loop
and do while loop so a loop statement in
java execute a set of statements until a
specific condition is satisfied so here
the one billion example so here you will
start from the zeroth count so that will
be the counter variable which counts the
number of reputations and followed by
the counter variable you will be having
the condition
so you will be having the count of
variable i i is less than or equal to
the number 1 billion so until that you
have to print this particular statement
and followed by that you will be having
the increment or decrement operator in
this case you need to use the increment
operator for the first time once the
print is done you will increment the
value to 2 and the loop will be iterated
once again so this will continue the
loop will iterate itself until one two
three four so on and until it reaches
one billionth number so that's when the
condition fails i is greater than or
equal to one billion so that's when the
condition fails the condition was to be
i should be less than or equal to 1
billionth so when the number increments
above 1 billion then the condition fails
so the condition was the number should
be less than or equal to billion but the
number has exceeded the billion so
that's when the loop terminates and
executes the next statement after the
loop so i think this was a little clear
about the loop workflow now to
understand the loops in a much more
better way let's execute an example for
each one of these types of loops so we
have follow while open do while loop
let's execute the program so all of
these three so you can see that we have
a program on my screen so this
particular program is based on for loop
so you can see that the quote part
highlighted on my editor is the follow
so you can see int i is equals to 1 so
this is the counter variable so i is the
counter variable which stores a number
from where the count should begin so
sometimes you can choose zero sometimes
one or the number of your choice so here
i've chosen the number one so after the
initialization part we have the
condition part so remember the one
billionth example we discussed before so
here we have i should be less than or
equal to 10. so this particular loop
segment will run until the condition
that is i value should be less than or
equal to 10 is satisfied once it turns
false the control will exit the for loop
so that's how it's designed to work with
now followed by the condition we have
the pre-increment operator once the
condition is checked the control will
jump to the next statement that is the
pre-increment operator and it increments
the value of 1 to 2. so this is how the
loop works now let's try to execute this
program and see the output there you go
the program got successfully executed
and the output has been printed so
basically what was the statement to be
executed it was a printf statement
looped plus here the plus symbol works
as a concatenation operator here too
now in between the printf statements we
have the value of i so in the first
place i was equals to 1 once the
pre-increment was taken place the value
of i will be increased to 2 so there you
go you can see the number 2 over there
now in the second iteration we print the
value looped two times similarly in the
third iteration looped three times so
that's how it works until the last
iteration that is looped 10 times so
once the condition is checked here the
control will enter into the next part
where the pre-increment takes place so
the pre-increment increments the value
of 10 to 11. now the control will come
back to the initialization part here we
have the new value for i that is 11 now
11 will be checked against the condition
is 11 less than or equal to 10
no right so the condition here fails now
the loop is terminated the control will
exit the loop so this is how the for
loop works
now let us also consider another example
for follow for a better understanding
so in this particular program we are
going to print the sum of n numbers
so in that particular n numbers we will
be having even numbers and odd numbers
for example consider that you have
provided the number as 5. so the numbers
in between 0 to 5 or 1 to 5 are 1 2 3 4
and 5. so the 4 is even number and apart
from 4 everything else are odd numbers
so odd numbers are the numbers which are
divisible by 1 or itself so now the sum
of odd numbers is 1 plus 2 is 3 3 plus 3
is 6 6 plus 5 is 11 so that's how you
print the sum of odd numbers and the sum
of even numbers that is only 4. so
that's how the loop works here you have
the condition if else condition and out
of that if else condition you have the
for loop so this particular loop should
be running until a given number that
will be given by you so that's how the
program works now let's quickly execute
this program and see the output so there
you go the program got successfully
executed and now it's asking for an
input let's check out five itself now
you can see we have another program on
my screen which is basically based on
the same for loop so here we have the
for loop we will be providing an input
which is num and inside that we have
another condition that is the if else
loop so basically if loop is dedicated
to find out the even numbers and l slope
is dedicated to find out the odd numbers
now the whole motto of this particular
program is to find the sum of even
numbers and the sum of odd numbers
between 0 to the input number which you
provide for example consider if we
provide the number 5 as the input then
in between 0 to 5 we have odd numbers
and even numbers so the even numbers are
2 and 4 and the odd numbers are 1 3 and
5. so basically what happens here is we
are going to add up the numbers so the
sum of even numbers that is 2 and 4s6
and sum of odd numbers that is 5 plus 3
is 8 8 plus 1 is 9. so that's how it
should work now let's quickly try to
execute this program and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and now it's
asking for an input now let's enter 5
itself and see the output so there you
go the sum of even numbers up to 5 is 6
and the sum of odd numbers up to 5 is 9.
so this is how the program works now
apart from for loop we also have another
way to declare the same for loop so that
particular type of for loop is called as
the enhanced for loop or in some cases
it's also called as advanced for loop
let's see how the for loop is declared
in a different way so instead of using
the typical for loop which has the
initialization state then the condition
then the pre increment or post increment
or decrement kind of operations we
simply have declared the for and inside
that we have end arr which is the name
of the variable of array type and inside
that we have the array so our array
consists of 10 numbers followed from 1
to 10 and now this particular loop will
execute for 10 times or until all the
values in the array are printed so now
let's try to print this so there you go
the program got successfully executed
and we have all our values from 1 to 10
which were the input or the saved part
of the array now with this let's
continue with the next kind of loop that
happens to be the while loop so you can
see an example based on while loop on my
screen so basically everything is same
uh there is no much of a difference
between for loop and while loop but the
only difference is the keyword instead
of for we have a while over here so
so we have the while condition over here
which says i should be less than or
equal to num divided by 2 and if this
condition is true then the control
should enter into the conditional
statement if num modulus i is equal to
equals to zero flag is equals to true
and prick so basically the whole motto
of this program is to find out if the
given particular number is a prime
number or not now let's quickly try to
run this program and see the output now
you can see the program got successfully
executed let us try to provide a prime
number and see if the program could
identify it correctly as a prime number
or not there you go the prime number we
provided was 5 and the program
successfully identified it as a prime
number so that's how the while loop
works
now let's execute another program based
on while loop but this time we will
place the condition at the end of the
loop so yeah you guessed it right this
is do while loop the only difference
between while loop and do while loop is
that before
the condition is checked in while loop
no statement is executed but it's
completely opposite when it comes to do
while loop first the program or the code
segment will be completely executed
after that the condition will be checked
surprising right let's check out the
practical part yeah we have our program
on my screen right now so
in the previous program we had the
condition somewhere over here that's the
file condition but here we have the do
statement here so what we are going to
do is we are conveying the compiler or
the interpreter to execute this
particular statement first without
checking the
while condition so this is the only
difference between while loop and
do-while loop so we have run the program
successfully and it got executed and we
were supposed to actually print the
values of i from 1 to 20 and they have
printed over here that's how it works
simple right choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
plus hours of video content for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
objects and classes in java this is a
part of our java tutorial series where
we will be covering everything you need
to know to master java let us look at
what we will cover today first we will
talk about objects and we will implement
two programs on intellij to learn about
objects then we will move on to classes
in java where we will see an advanced
program to learn classes more in depth
so what are objects an object is an
instance of a class let's have a look at
an example in this example animal is a
class and dog is its object the object
dog has states and behaviors we can have
dogs with different breeds sizes and
colors these are considered as the
states of object dog on behavior side
dog has behavior like barking eating and
wagging tail so an object has its own
states and behaviors now let's look at
an example using java code there are
many platforms to run java program so
for this video i'll be using intellij so
let's create a new project let's name it
as project 1 and finish there we go we
have a new project with we have a class
with main and we have a main function so
the code that we write should always be
written in the main function so let's
create a new class to understand how the
object is used let's name it as student
we need variables so that we can access
the variables of this class so i'm gonna
use
student id with the integer type student
name
and student's age
there we go now we have these three
variables that we can use so let's go to
our main program and start our coding so
we have a class named student now let's
see how to create a object of a class
this is the syntax to create object now
the object here is s i created a object
as of class student now let's assign
values to the variables for this we use
the object s and use the dot operator
and we have options from which we can
choose from that we declared in the
class student so for this i'll use id
and give a value similarly i'll give age
and give a value and finally let's give
a name
now we'll print its value
now we are going to run this program
let's see what output will get
and there it is we have name
that's simply learn we have age and we
have id
now let us see an example how we can use
multiple objects for a single class so
let's get started let's create a new
project and i'm gonna name it as
vehicles because i'm gonna use cars and
bikes in this program so i'm gonna use
vehicles as a combined form and yes here
we have a class main and a function main
now i need two classes for this program
so i'm gonna create two classes first
i'm gonna name it as bikes and the
second class i'm gonna name it as cars
so let's create variables for these
classes so in cars first i need string
name
and i need the cost of the car so cost
can be integer as well because i'm gonna
use dollar sign in that so i'm gonna use
string because of that so same thing i'm
gonna do with bikes
now that our classes are created let's
create objects for this class so the
process is same but we are going to use
different names for the object first the
car class and i'm going to name as car1
and yes we have created the first object
now to create the second object
similarly i am going to create five
objects of the class cars
and i'm gonna change the name for them
so i created five objects of the same
class so i'm gonna create five objects
of the bike's class as well so bike one
will be a bit longer so i'm gonna use b1
till b5
and i'm going to name them to from b1 to
b5 so now i'm going to assign values to
the variables that i created in classes
bike and cars so first i'm going to go
with cars and let's name it as
lamborghini similarly
car to ferrari
so i'm gonna use names of the cars that
are very famous and costly so that
anyone over the world can understand
this so let's name car three
i'm gonna name it as bugatti
similarly car four
pagani and
now i am going to give names for bikes
i hope everyone will understand the
names that i give
b4
and b5
last one
yamaha
now let's assign the cost for bikes and
cars as well so the procedure is same so
let's do it 130 000
same b2 so b1 goes for harley davidson
b2 for ducati b3 for suzuki b4 for e cos
and b5 for yamaha i'm gonna assign
values for these values accordingly for
ducati 232 000
for suzuki 200 000
300 000
and the last one yamaha 500 000
now similarly i'm going to assign values
for carbon.cost till card five dot cost
two hundred three thousand dollars for
lambo i think i can copy paste these as
well
so let's
copy paste a lot faster and easier to do
car 2 car 3
car 4 and car
we don't need this
uh as for car two let's take it as 252
000 and
let's make it it's three million
as per this let's keep it as
1 million
400 000 and lastly uh let's see is 293
now that we have assigned all the values
for all this now let's print it and get
the value i'm gonna create a very simple
program but a very user-friendly program
so it's gonna be interesting for you
guys so we are going to ask the users
what would they like either bikes or
cars so we need to give them the options
and our next program will be based on
the options that the users select not
the options we give as the command so
let's do it
let's give the options one
[Music]
bikes
and two cars
i need to take the value that user gives
for this i'm gonna write this command
so i have not used scanner yet so let's
import
scanner
and let's create a object for scanner
and yes let's get back so the data type
of choice variable is integer that's why
i'm using next int if the data type was
string then i would have used next line
so now that we have choice from the user
let's use this value
if the user chooses the first value that
means bikes so the next thing we display
is we have models and we are going to
give five models for bikes to the user
here i am giving options to the users so
that they can choose easily from number
one to five
now we can show these options to the
users so that they can choose from one
of these value so let's use one more if
statement so that we can find out
whether they have this value or not
before that i am going to ask which one
would you like to choose
to enter the choice i am going to use
one more variable lets say n so i am
going to store n
if n is equal to equal to 1 that means
harley davidson then i'm gonna show the
cost of harley davidson
this is the syntax to print the value
for the cost or any of the variable that
we use in class
what if the user says second or third or
fourth or fifth so for that we are going
to use else if statements
if n is 2 that means ducati so we have
to show the rate of ducati or the cost
of ducati to the user
now similarly i'm going to do for n is
equal to 3 n is equal to 4 and n is
equal to 5.
now i'm gonna do for n is equal to 4
and lastly n is equal to 5 that is a
last bike yamaha
what if the users put a number that is
not between one to five so for that i am
going to use else statement and put a
message that please enter the value from
1 and 5.
so now we have code for the bikes and
the same thing whatever the user selects
that he wants to find the car so for
that we have this the choice is equal to
is equal to one so the same thing we are
going to do for choice is equal to is
equal to 2
and the same thing we are going to tell
to user that we have 5 models
same names that i gave to variables i'm
gonna give this to here
second one ferrari
third book rt
fourth e
course
and the last one
posh
now we are going to ask the users their
choice that which number do they want to
choose
now we need one more value so that we
can have it as a variable which can
store the choice of the user so for this
i am going to use c
now if c is equal to equal to 1 that
means if the user wants to see the cost
of lamborghini that he puts the choice
as 1 so we are going to display this
message the cost of lamborghini
and we are going to use else if loop to
enter the next values for c from 1 to 5.
if c is equal to is equal to 2 that
means the user wants to know the rate of
ferrari then we are going to show the
cost of the ferrari
same thing if the user enters 3 as the
choice
if user enters 4 as their choice
then we go for ecos
and the last one if user enters the
choice as 5
then we have to display the cost of posh
now what if the user enters none of the
values from 1 to 5 then we have to
display a message
showing that
please enter the value
between
one to five now remember the first
choice that we wanted from user to enter
either bikes or cars so what if the user
do not enter either one or two so for
that we need one more else function to
tell the user that either enter one or
two
and with this we have completed our code
so now let's run this program for this
we need to go to run and then run main
there's a shortcut for it that is shift
plus f10 so let's run the program
and yes we have successfully executed
the program let's test this program now
so enter your choice i'm gonna enter one
and yeah we have five models harley
davidson ducati suzuki pagani and yamaha
so enter your choice i'm gonna enter one
and yeah we have our result the cost of
harley davidson is 130 000
so with this we have completed our code
and please feel free to type this code
in your own computer and try out all the
permutation and combinations that you
can with this program so with this let's
move on to classes and understand the
classes and their concept then we'll
have a new program on classes now let's
see what is a class a class is a
blueprint from which objects are created
a class describes state or behavior of
an object in this example dog is a class
the variables in this class are breed
and color the functions or methods of
the class dog are barking hungry and
sleeping we use objects of a class to
use variables and functions of the class
with this let's understand classes with
a simple java code let's create a new
project
next tick the box and let's name it as
automobiles
let the base package be student and yes
we have a class
main now let's create some classes to do
code on
i'll create a new java class as cars
and then i'll create one more class with
the name bikes
and then one more class automobiles
so i am gonna connect cars and bikes
with automobiles so that we can use that
program in main and see what can we do
with the classes that we create in
automobiles i need some variables
i'll take private double and let's say
fuel and then same thing private double
and then year and let's take one more
private string
and brand now let's have getters and
setters for this so these are used to
get the value and set the value for the
variables inside the class
there we go
we have the getters and setters for it
now let's go to class cars
so public class cars extends automobiles
so in it i'm gonna create one more class
or a constructor
and i'm gonna print a message say a new
car has been created
car has been created now the same thing
i'm gonna do with bikes let's go to
bikes and
i'm gonna use the same thing extends
automobiles
this is because i can inherit all the
variables from the automobiles class
so i created a constructor and i'm gonna
print a message
a new bike has been created
so i have created class cars bikes and
automobiles so let's go to main program
so this is where we should write our
code so i'm gonna start with the code
now it's a very simple code i'm gonna
first i'm gonna create
the variables or the objects of the
class with private
bikes bike so one is car and one is bike
both are objects for the classes so i'm
going to use these objects
bikes bike is equal to new bike
this is so that my object can function
really well and now i'm gonna run it
it'll take some time to run
and yes there we go our program has
executed and the things that i typed a
new car has been created a new bike has
been created are done now let's try
something else using the classes
so i'm going to bikes
so i'm going to create a new method or a
new function
public void cake for bike so i'm gonna
print message
the bike has been started with kick
bike has been started
with kick now the same thing i'm gonna
do with cars now how does a car start
with the key so i'm gonna make a
function public key and inside it i'm
gonna print the same message car has
been started with key i should write
void there to give the return value as
wide
so let's print the message
car has been started
with key rotation let's write that as
well so in the main program i'm going to
use objects to use those functions and
let's see what changes they'll do to our
program
pike dot cake and car dot cake let's run
this
and there we go first we used to have
this two messages but now these two
messages are also there as well because
we invoked those functions and methods
that are there in class cars and bikes
so if i write bike dot key
or
car dot kick
this won't work this is because key is
not a method of bike or kick is not a
method of car so that's why i gave
private static for the functions
so if i execute it these are the error
messages that i'll get cannot find the
symbol method kick or method key
what is an abstract class
the answer is abstraction is one of the
keys to achieving an object-oriented
programming approach and designing a
software
here the programmer tries to hide the
complicated implementation of the code
which makes the software run smoothly
most of the time the user isn't
interested to know how the code is being
implemented so through abstraction we
can just hide it
to do so we use an abstract class or
sometimes an interface based on the
requirement
so abstract class in java is considered
as a template of methods and variables
which are used in a program
remember abstract classes cannot be
instantiated directly
now moving ahead we will next learn the
important features of abstract classes
so the first one is template
the main reason programmers prefer to
use abstract methods is because they act
as a predefined template
for any future specific class that you
might use
next loose coupling is a procedure where
an internal object gets the necessary
method or a different object from the
external world that is other than the
current working project the use of
abstract classes makes this process
possible
after that we have the code reusability
implementation of the abstract classes
provides the developers with one of the
greatest features that saves time which
is none other than the code reusability
followed by code reusability we have
abstraction as discussed earlier data
abstraction is the process of hiding
certain details and showing only
essential information to the user
abstraction can be achieved with either
abstract classes or interfaces
last but not the least
dynamic method resolution
the abstract classes enable us with
dynamic method resolution or the dynamic
method dispatch process
the dynamic method resolution is a
mechanism by which a call to an
overridden method is resolved at runtime
this is how java implements runtime
polymorphism
when an overridden method is called by
reference
java determines which version of that
method to execute based on the type of
object it refers to
now these were the few important
features of abstract classes next in the
docket is the crucial rules to be
followed to use abstract classes
alright let us go through the rules one
by one as mentioned below
the first one is
the keyword abstract is mandatory to
declare an abstract class followed by
that the next rule says that abstract
classes cannot be instantiated directly
the third one is an abstract class must
have at least one abstract method
next to that we have another rule which
says an abstract class includes final
methods
next an abstract class may also include
non-abstract methods
it's not mandatory that an abstract
class should only include abstract
methods so the last rule says that an
abstract class
can include constructors and static
methods
so these were some crucial rules to be
followed to use abstract classes in java
so far we have discussed the definition
of abstract classes its features and the
rules to use abstract classes in java
now we will learn how to achieve
abstraction in java
so basically there are two different
ways to achieve abstraction in java the
first way is by using abstract classes
and the next one is by using an
interface
now this brings us to our next topic
that is the syntax to be followed to use
an abstract class and an abstract method
to declare an abstract class we use the
keyword called abstract followed by that
we use the keyword called class
then after that we declare the name of
our class
the name of the class is up to the
user's choice for example i have named
my class as simply learn as shown here
followed by the abstract class we have
the abstract method to declare an
abstract method we use the keyword
called abstract then the written type of
the method as of now i have used void
then later we have the name of the
method that is based on the user's
choice as you can see i have used
simplylearn as the name of the method
so this was by using abstractlast method
the next one is by using an interface
method
now what exactly is an interface
so interface can be defined as a
boundary
between the method and the class
implementing it in java we use interface
to achieve abstraction
in other words we can also consider
interface as a container which saves the
signatures of the methods used in a
program
now we will move ahead and understand
the syntax
to use an interface to achieve
abstraction in java
to declare an interface we use the
keyword called interface followed by
that we declare the name of a class
the class name is up to the user's
choice for example i have named my class
as simply learn as shown below
as discussed earlier interface acts just
as a container that stores only the
signatures of the method we cannot have
a complete method defined inside it all
we can do is just declare an interface
now that we have a detailed explanation
about the abstract class and the
interface
let us look into some example programs
based on abstract classes
now we have successfully booted the
eclipse ide now let's create a new
project
so to create a new project just click on
create a project
and this should give you a dialog box
wherein you have to select java project
click next
now let us give a name to our project
so simply learn will be the name of my
project here now let me click on finish
to finish this process
as you can see the project has been
successfully created
and inside the project simply learn we
have the source file and right clicking
the source file will give us a dropbox
where you can just select new and inside
new you can select a new package
now let's name the package as
abstraction and click on finish to
create the package
moving further let's right click on the
package and select new and from new
select a class to create a new class
so the name of my class will be employee
let's click on finish to create the
class
now we have our employee class ready
now let's right click on the package and
select new and inside that
let us select another class
and the name of this particular class
will be person
which will act as our abstract class
so as you can see we have declared this
particular class with the keyword
abstract and the name of the class is
person
so our first example which is based on
employees where we will have an abstract
class called person
and
this person class will be inherited by
the employee class
and gets executed to generate employee
details
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
to execute the program just right click
on the package and go to the run option
and select the first one that is java
application
now you can see we have the employee
name pavitra
and the gender is female and the
employee has logged in successfully so
these are the details which we were
expecting to be presented on the output
console
now moving ahead we shall execute our
next example which will be based on
students
so here
the class student is the abstract class
and three different student classes
namely raju pranita and punit will
inherit the student class and generate
the output that displays their
particular ranks
so you can see our abstract class that a
student is being declared using the
keyword abstract and inside that we have
an abstract method which is get rank
and these classes that are
raju pranita and punit will inherit the
abstract class student and display their
ranks
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
as you can see the three classes have
successfully inherited the abstract
class and displayed their ranks on the
output console
now let us move ahead and try to execute
one last example
based on abstract classes
so the third and last example is based
on interest rates provided by different
banks
here we have an abstract class named
loan and all the banks described in the
program will inherit the loan abstract
class to calculate the rate of interest
on the loans provided by them
as you can see we have the abstract
class that is loan and inside that we
have the abstract method which is
interest so we have the classes andhra
bank bank of baroda idbc bank state bank
of india which are inheriting the
abstract class called loan and the
method interest to display their rates
of interest now let us try to execute
this program and see the output
as you can see the program got
successfully executed and the rate of
interest for loans from different banks
has been displayed in the output console
so with this we have entered into our
next topic where we understand the
differences between an abstract class
and an interface
so the first difference between the both
is the keyword
while we declare an interface we use the
keyword called interface
on the other hand when we declare an
abstract class we use the keyword
abstract
followed by that the second difference
is
when you use an interface the subclasses
basically implement an interface
while on the other hand when you use
abstract classes the subclasses extend
an abstract class and inherit the
properties of the abstract class
followed by that the third difference is
multiple interfaces can be implemented
but on the other hand only one abstract
class can be extended at one particular
instance
and the final difference between the
both is
interface is capable to support multiple
inheritance
whereas on the other hand abstract
classes are not capable to support
multiple inheritances multiple
inheritance is none other than the
diamond problem which is not supported
in java
now that we have understood the
differences between the both let us
understand the major advantages and
disadvantages of using an abstract class
now first we will discuss the advantages
so the advantages of using an abstract
class in java are
the abstract classes are highly
beneficial in writing shorter codes
the abstract classes avoid code
duplication
they enable code reusability which is a
major advantage
and finally the last advantage is
changes to the internal code
implementation can be done without
affecting the classes
so these were few of the major
advantages of using an abstract class
now moving ahead we shall discuss the
disadvantages of using abstract losses
few of the disadvantages of using an
abstract class in java are
abstraction is expensive as sometimes
you need to handle cases and situations
which are not necessary
followed by that the second disadvantage
is
object relational impedance mismatch in
the case of rdbms and the last
disadvantage is object relational
mapping in case of frameworks like
hibernate
so these are the few important
disadvantages of using abstract classes
in java that you need to consider before
using them into your project
let's see the definition of
encapsulation encapsulation is like a
capsule the whole code and data is
bounded together into a single unit
another way to think about encapsulation
is it is a protective shield that
prevents the data from being accessed by
the code outside this shield as you can
see variables and methods are defined
inside one class like a capsule now the
question is why do we need encapsulation
the main reasons are first better
control of class attributes and methods
second class attributes can be made
read-only or write-only third it makes
java code very flexible this means the
programmer can change one part of the
code without affecting other parts apart
from these encapsulation is mainly used
to protect data and increase security of
the code as you can see to protect the
data variables must be private and they
can only be accessed through methods now
let's see java code for encapsulation to
understand the concept better so now
let's create a new project
next
next and i'm gonna name it as
ncap one
so here we have a main class
we can write the code here so before i
take the code let me create a new class
right click new java class
and i'm gonna name it as employee
so in this program we are going to use a
classic example of employee using
employee name id and salary so in this
class let me create variables
first string name
then
[Music]
integer id
and then in salary
so i can easily use these variables in
our main program by creating object of
the class so let me just create the
object
employee e is equal to new employee
now i can use e dot id name or salary
anything i need to but this program is
about encapsulation so this is an easy
program we can do but in order to secure
our programs when we have a large number
of program and large number of lines in
a program so we need encapsulation at
that time so that data can be secured
so for that i'm gonna name it as private
now all three variables are private so i
can't use them see we can't see them
anymore if i write id
we'll get a red color here so if we go
on it we can see id has private access
so that means we can't use it directly
because of this we need
getters and setters that are normally
methods that are used for these so right
click
generate
and here you can see getters and setters
so just select all of them
and ok
so now we can use these methods instead
of direct using the variables so we can
get in the starting then set then get
and again set so likewise it goes like
this
so now we have set here so
if i want to declare variable and if i
want to put some value inside my
variable so how can i do that
here you can see get id or get salary so
if i go for get id sorry if i go for e
dot set id and i set it as 6
so
this shows no error this means we can
use methods to access variables so let's
complete our program now first i am
going to set everything
and lastly e dot
set salary let's get it as 30 000
maybe in dollars or maybe in rupees
let's just set it as 30 000 for now
so how i'm gonna print it for this i'm
gonna go to a print statement and then
name
and e dot not set name but this time i'm
gonna go with get name get name is to
return the value of the name that i have
given so in this case that simply learn
and next will be id
and e dot get id
and lastly
salary
e dot get salary
so this is a simple program that is used
to define encapsulation we don't use
private variables that becomes a normal
program so when we use encapsulation we
are going to use private every time
whenever we declare variables so that
it's secure and no one can access the
variables directly
so now let's run the program
and there we go we have our result we
have executed the program successfully
and as you can see name simply learn id
6 and salary is 30 000
so i hope you understood the concept of
encapsulation so the main concept of
encapsulation is all the variables can
be accessed through methods so for this
we use getters and setters that are
inbuilt functions for intellij or
netbeans or eclipse so with this let's
move on to our next program to
understand it better and how we can
manipulate these variables or methods
using program so again let's create a
new project
and this time i'm gonna name it as
encapsulation 2 because it's the second
program for encapsulation
and here we have our main program
now this time i'm gonna use an example
of cars so let me just create a new
class and i'm gonna name it as cars
so in this again i'm gonna create three
variables that are private
so first i'm gonna get string name
then private string
price
that means price of the car
and third one
top speed of the car
so we can create the program that we did
before as it is but i'm gonna explain
you more in depth how we can manipulate
these variables or classes so i'm gonna
create a constructor for the class cars
and inside i'm gonna give it as
arguments as string name
then string
price
and string top speed
and i'm gonna give it as this dot name
is equal to name
this is so that the class can identify
that we are going to give arguments
related to that and the class can return
the values of it
so similarly i'm gonna give it as this
dot price
is equal to price
and lastly
this top speed is equal to
top speed
so with this we have completed our
constructor for it now let's have
getters and setters for the same thing
for these three variables
so generate
getter and setter
select all and ok
this is a great feature that we have in
java getters and setters otherwise we'll
have to type the whole code so with this
let's move on to our main program
we'll write the code here first i'll
create object of the class cars
and inside this i'm gonna give arguments
or inside this i'm gonna give values
that i use in constructor to assign the
values without using any c dot get name
or c dot get price
so my first was name so let me just name
it as bmw
the second thing was price so i'm going
to give it as 30 000
and the third one was top speed so top
speed i'm gonna give it as
200 kilometer per hour so we have
assigned all the values to the variables
and we have created object as well all
in the same line so this is another way
of creating objects or another way of
assigning values to the variables that
are private
so if i try to print these they can be
easily printed
so in the starting name
and c dot
so this time i'm gonna give get name so
it automatically gets the value that i
assigned to the variables through
getters and setters
after that price
price c dot price get price
and in the end
top speed
c dot get top speed
so if i print this
let's execute it
and there we go we have name bmw price
and even the top speed now if i give
spaces between them
it will look neatly
so let me execute it once more
and here you go
name bmw price 30 000 and top speed 200
kilometer per hour so this is one of our
ways how we can declare variables or
assign values to the variables without
using any getters or setters so in this
method we used only getters to print the
value that we have for variables now how
can we manipulate the variables if we
want to change value of them
now for this again i can do set top
speed or set price let the name be as it
is
so c dot set price
so price i'm gonna set it as
fifty thousand dollars
and c dot set top speed let me increase
it to 250 kilometer per
hour so before printing that and so that
we can differentiate which one is new
and which one is old i'm gonna print one
more line
stats after
updation
so now if i print these values i'm just
going to copy paste it
so now if i print it let's execute it
and here you go
first we have name price and top speed
then stats after updations that means
after we set the value the value gets
overwritten on the variables and now we
have a new price and top speed and all
the details so this is how you can
manipulate variables or values inside
the variables
what is inheritance
there are two other key terms which are
not going to be in this agenda but you
should also
when you get to them make sure you
bundle them together as you're
understanding these structures and
that's the abstract class and the
polymorphism
so what is inheritance
inheritance is an act through which a
new class gets created by acquiring the
variables and methods defined in the
previous parent class
so we look at what is inheritance we can
take an example of say food we have
veggies noodles fruits
where food is the parent and your
veggies your noodles and fruits are all
subclasses of that they're all kind of
children of food
why do we need inheritance
we implement inheritance for a multiple
of reasons like creating a possibility
to add or remove features
to reduce the code length as we reuse
the code
more comfortable to develop and maintain
the project
and so if we start looking at let's say
we have a cell phone we make calls we
have our sms texting our communication
on our phone we have our media we also
had a browser on there because now we
have a smartphone
and we look at that we have our phones
set up and then we have our
full smartphone media call sms and
browser
and we start to kind of link these
instead of making them separate we can
have the call and the text
and then we can have them inherit we can
actually create a media that inherits
their quality so now you can text your
media now you can use the browser as
part of your call scenario
and i would even add one more example in
here and that is that all programming
languages that are object based are
built on inheritance uh java python c
plus plus so this concept of building an
object and then that object then is
inherited by everything underneath of it
is important to understand even in these
most even as we're looking at more
specific cases
so take a look at the components of
inheritance
and the most important two components in
inheritance the two major components
that are mentioned are parent class or
the super class in the child class or
the subclass
and to see this let's go ahead and
jump into eclipse and take a look at
what the actual code looks like
so the first thing i want to do is go
ahead and add in a new
package
and we're going to go ahead and call
this package um inheritance because
that's what we're working with
oops
give me a default java tutorial in there
inheritance finish
and i started off with the java
tutorials just a um
went in and created a new project and
made sure it was java based
so we have our package inheritance right
here we're going to go and add in a new
class
and we'll go ahead and call this class
machine
now one of the standards when you're
creating classes to capitalize the first
letter so always remember to do that
in some places people like to have the
whole word capitalized it really depends
on who you're working with but it is
kind of if it starts with a capital
letter it's probably a class
and so once we have our inheritance we
have our public class machine
let's go ahead and give it a little bit
underneath there to do something and
we'll start with
a
protected
string brand
and so whatever machine we're working
with
these particular machines are going to
be
we'll call them sam it'll be a samsung
free uh
they get some free vocab free marketing
right there for samsung
so samsung machines
and we wanted to do something so let's
go ahead and put a procedure in there
and we'll make it public
void because it's not going to return
anything
and we'll call this
wash i guess they're all wash machines
there we go there's our brackets a
little trouble finding the bracket on
there and let's just have it uh during
this we'll just have it do a quick uh
print line
and we'll say um
initiating
cycle
there and then of course our semicolon
on the end
all right so now we have a public class
machine and we're going to get into
where we start working with the actual
inheritance
you can create an object with this
machine we haven't done anything special
to it it's like any other
class you might create in the java
language and we've added in public
void wash a procedure with no return
that's what the void means and it's
going to print out and so let's go ahead
and create another
class in here
new class
and this one's going to be washing
machine
washing
and uh
we'll go ahead and hit finish on here
and we come into our washing machine
this opened up a nice new tab for us
and we might have a private string
model name
and we'll change this to model type
model type equals
so type of machine is is a top load
washing machine
so we have a samsung is the main type of
machines we're looking at we have top
loader or top loading washing machine
and then we're going to add up here
extends
machine
and so this is the the key code we're
going to look for because um we want
this to have the properties of the
machine
so this comes in and says whatever is in
machine we now also have in our washing
machine
and then of course if we're going to do
all this we need to actually be able to
run it and if we're going to do that we
want to go ahead and add in the public
static
void main reserved
keywords there
and this is just your standard main uh
startup you have your string of
arguments
um there we go
and of course our bracket
and then in here
we're going to take and create a washing
machine object
and so here's our wash machine
it's of course the type washing machine
and it's going to equal a new
washing machine so we're initiating a
new object in here there we go
and then we want to do something
and if we're going to have it do
something we wanted to go ahead
let's see what happens we have wash
remember our keyword up there was
washing machine dot
wash
and where did that come from well if you
go back into machine
here it is public void wash there's the
procedure
and it's coming into the washing machine
and this is inherited
that way we don't have to retype that
every time we have a washing machine
this could be washing machine
maybe the next one is
i don't know different kind of washing
machines i'm not an expert on washing
machines
we have it do a wash
and then specific to the washing machine
in here
we also have uh the type
and so we can come back up here or brand
so we can come up down here we can go
system
dot
print line
wash
machine
dot
brand plus
a little dash in there
plus
and then we're going to go ahead and we
have our wash
machine dot
model type
that model type we put in there
uh so the brand where does the brand
come from the brand's coming from our
machine we have our protected string
which is going to be samsung
and then we have our washing machine
which has the model type which is a top
load machine
and if we go ahead and run this
after of course we make sure we have
that semicolon in on the end there
we come up there we'll see initiating
cycle initiating cycle is printed out
from machine and then the samsung top
load washing machine is the second
printout line here
and so when we have our wash print out
here also the wash machine wash
this initiating cycle and then we have
that's where that printout comes from we
can go back up here to machine you can
see right here initiating cycle
and then we flip back over to the
washing machine we print out wash
machine.brand
which is the machine class and then wash
machine dot model type which is
underneath the washing machine
so let's go over all that let's take a
look and see what we're talking about
here
so we saw on the code the extends
keyword
the term extends is a pretty defined
keyword in java that allows you to
create a new child class by deriving the
variables and methods from the parent
class to reduce code links and improve
the performance
and we see that right up here in our
public class washing machine extends
machine
so the next key thing to talk about is
access modifiers
and i kind of breezed over them when i
put together the code but we'll dig in
there a little deeper
we talk about access modifiers
there's four different words you really
need to know that's default
public protected and private
and i'm going to tell you right now
default equals public
so what is default default access
modifier is set implicitly whenever you
declare a class without a specific
access modifier
by default the access of a class or
method when declared without a specific
access modifier becomes available to any
other method or class within the same
package
and in java the default is public so
public a certain class can be declared
as public by using the keyword public
any class or method when declared as
public becomes available to any class or
method declared in the same package
but if a different method or class needs
it it should be imported
and then we have protected a certain
class is declared protected by using the
keyword protected
this provides access to the methods and
variables of the protected class only to
the rightful subclasses and protects the
data from any other classes which are
not related
and then private a certain class is
declared protected by using the keyword
private
this provides the ultimate protection to
the data members and the methods of the
private class this procedure is
implemented by class to encapsulate the
method and members
so
we'll take a little we're actually going
to do a different example in here but i
do like this underneath the washing
machine
you can see right here we have put in
private a private string
what this means is that only washing
machine can access that private
string where if you have protected the
children can access it
so a protected screen if you're
underneath a machine up here we have
protected
so that when i create the washing
machine and extend machine
i can still access it but if i create a
sub
class of washing machine and i mark it
as private that subclass is not going to
be able to access it and so it has to do
with what layers of accessing
think of this as a big team project
you create something do you really want
that to cascade down to the next class
or who do you want to have access to
that
let's go a little deeper to really bring
this home because it's really important
to understand this terminology
let's go ahead and start a new class
here and we're just going to call this
particular class
summation
and go ahead and create that finish
and so our summation class is going to
be pretty simple in here
we'll go ahead and do
public
so anything but he can access it just
remember here's our public on there
and then we'll just do a
anti-jerks that's what it's going to
return as an integer
we're going to call it add
and we're going to put integer x comma
integer y
and
then we'll just return x plus y so real
simple we're just adding two numbers
here's our two inputs they both have to
be integers and we're going to return an
integer and it'll be the summation of
the two so real simple class right there
and if we're going to have a summation
then let's go ahead and create a new
class we'll call this one child
and in our new child class
we're going to go ahead and keep this
simple and we're just going to have our
public static main
we're going to have our summation a
equals new summation
and then system out print line a dot add
100 plus 200.
pretty straightforward everything's
public in here um oops okay
there's our running and we see that
answer is 300.
so this is public if you remember
quickly we're talking about public
and so when we use the public keyword
any class or method when declared as
public becomes available to any class or
method declared in the same package
but if in a different method or class
needs it it should be imported
so here we go that's our public setup
it's just open to everybody
well everybody that's under the package
inheritance so whoever's using that
package can now use the this particular
child
and let's go ahead and add a new class
in and this time we're going to do a
parent class
i'll just put that right in there
and we come in with our parent class you
can see right here the parent class
itself is public but we want to do
underneath the parent class is we want
to create a protected
void because we're not returning
anything and print so we're going to do
the print there
and this protected print let's go and
put our brackets in there and we'll do
just a simple uh print line hello world
and once we have the the print hello
world we want to go ahead and add a
child class to this
and let's see we already well we had the
child class when it took it out a second
ago so we'll go ahead and put that back
in here's our child class
and before this child of class we wanted
to go ahead and extend the parent
so inheritance there's our extend on
there oops let me type that
all right extends parent so now the
child class is part of the parent class
and we'll go ahead and put our main in
there so that it will run it and execute
it and we'll create our child x
equals new
child class
let me go ahead and assign our variable
x and initiate it and then we'll do just
the print and see what happens here so
here's our print statement
and we'll go ahead and run this and
compile our child on there
and when it comes in there you see it
says print hello world and so the parent
has marked this as protected so it's
protected from
objects that are not inheriting it but
the child can still access that
information and print it on there
so here's protected this provides access
to methods and variables of the
protected class only to the rightful
subclasses and protects the data from
any other classes which are not related
and a lot of programming that's usually
where you end up is doing a lot of stuff
that is
underneath your parent
that is protected either make them
public or protected a lot of people are
sloppy and just make them public but
most of stuff you want to make sure it's
protected and then we finally have our
private and i'm going to go back here to
our child and we're going to
run this
and it's going to come up and say
proceed with launch errors in
setup and then it's going to give us an
exception thread main
compilation error the method print from
the type parent is not visible
and that's because unless you actually
initiate the parent
you're not going to see this code
because it's private it's only private
to the public to the parent class so
even if i extend it in child
it will not be available and that again
protects it that means it's something
that you don't want to inherit and
cascade down because maybe it is a piece
of code that is going to be changed and
so you don't want all the children to
crash every time you make a change to it
so with private this provides the
ultimate protection to the data members
in the methods of the private class
this procedure is implemented by class
to encapsulate the methods and members
so very important we have private and we
have protected and we have public the
more access you want other pieces of the
software code to have and other
programmers they have the more public
you want to make it and of course the
default is public
now one of the common workarounds for
this because you only have protected
data but you still want it to be used by
the subclasses
is to create what they call like a get
or a um and we'll do it up here
we'll go ahead and do a
private
integer x equals five
and then instead of
on your inheritance instead of having it
uh
call it from
the child we might have a get thing or a
github get thing
we might have a public
return an integer
and we might have it say get x
and this simply just return
x
and what this means is that when we have
something simple like this where it just
doesn't return x i can go back into my
child here
and instead of print x we'll do
x dot
get x
and we'll go ahead and print this out
or you know something simple with that
we'll go ahead and do a uh
system print line on this
and when we run this
you'll see it come up it's going to
recompile and we get our five
what's happening here is now i've
created underneath the parent private
information you don't know what's going
on with it it's protected
you might have a procedure that's
protected in this case we had the print
procedure and then we access it from the
public and this could have easily have
been instead of maybe we'll just call it
public
void
public print
kind of a goofy way of doing the code
there we go and then it could go in here
and access our
print
and so we can actually still access this
print variable up here by wrapping it in
kind of a get or a
public function this allows us to
protect whatever code is going on in the
parent class so it can't be messed up it
can't be accessed indirectly it has to
go through the right processes and so
when we get to the child on here
the child can then still has the public
processes but all the other information
isn't is protected and is private it's
really important to remember that
private right there
this brings us to super key word
and we talk about the super keyword a
super keyword eliminates the confusion
between parent class method and sub
class method
super keyword is implemented to access a
method or constructor that is defined in
the parent class
so back in eclipse we'll go under parent
and we'll take this we're going to
take the private out of there so now we
have an integer 5
and we'll go ahead and just remove the
print because we're not going to do that
in the parent
um oops and the public
there we go
and so let's create a parent that just
has one piece of information it has an
integer x equals 5.
and then we're going to go to the child
and let's go ahead and add in here
integer
x equals 10.
and these are by default they're public
we haven't set anything on here telling
it what it is
and so what i'd like to do is we'd like
to go ahead and create
a
oops one more thing there we go create a
procedure here and we'll just call this
void capital print
it's just going to be a system out print
line and this is what i want you to
notice is we're going to print out x